a deal has been signed to allow the
resumption of grain shipments from
ukrainian ports on the black sea
following months of russian blockades
representatives from both sides attended
the signing in istanbul along with
turkish president recep tayyip erdogan
and u.n secretary general antonio
guterres it's hoped that reopening the
ports and allowing grain to leave
ukraine will help ease global food
prices which have spiked in recent
months
and the signing ceremony mr gutierrez
stressed the deal significance calling
it an agreement for the world
it will bring relief for developing
countries on the edge of bankruptcy and
the most vulnerable people on the edge
of famine
and it will help stabilize global food
prices which were already at record
levels even before the war
through nightmare for developing
countries
let's join dw correspondent julia han in
istanbul welcome julia sounds like a lot
of people will be breathing huge sighs
of relief this afternoon
exactly i think so and not just here in
istanbul but around the world people
have been following these negotiations
in the past weeks in the past months
even and now finally
a deal has been signed i think it's fair
to say that this is one of the most
significant compromises or the most
significant compromise reached between
moscow and kiev since russia invaded
ukraine in february the un secretary
general hailed it as an accordion here a
beacon of hope but he also urged all
sides to fully implement this agreement
turkish president erdogan who also
played a key role in negotiating this
deal
called it a turning point in this war he
said vessel traffic could start and i
quote him in the coming days of course
it remains to be seen how fast this
whole plan can be put into action
because some have cautioned that it
actually might take a couple of weeks to
get this whole
new grain export system up and running
but right now as the war in ukraine
rages on i believe for many this is a
sign of hope at least
so who has committed to what in this
deal uh julia
well the the actual text of the
agreement has still not been made
available as we speak but
we do know um that the plan provides for
ukrainian vessels to escort or guard
cargo ships through mined water so the
waters will not be specifically demined
wire the black sea out of ukrainian
territorial waters towards
turkey both sides have made promises
that they would not attack these ships
now there is also going to be a
coordination center to be set up here in
istanbul at this uh
strategically very important black sea
location uh staffed by representatives
of russia ukraine and turkey to oversee
the grain exports and also to conduct
inspections of these ships that was a
specific russian demand that all ships
cargo ships traveling to ukraine or
coming back would be inspected to make
sure there are no weapons or military
equipment on board but ukraine said they
wanted uh that to take place in turkish
water so uh we're assuming right now
that's exactly how it's gonna look like
right because trust has been a big issue
uh in these talks for both sides
uh well that that is of course true and
i've just you know mentioned a few
points and there's obviously very
complex agreement but for the ukrainians
security has always been a top priority
and they said they would not approve
anything that does not guarantee the
safety of their southern regions and the
security of their of the exports of
their agricultural uh
products and ukraine as we all know has
accused russia in recent weeks of uh you
know um specifically uh targeting and
more frequently targeting ukrainian
cities so ukraine has always been
warning that you know they they can
trust russian promises specifically on
security and i think that will remain a
sticking point
thank you for that uh julie at yulia han
in istanbul
we'll take a look at this from a
different angle with david labord who's
a senior fellow at the international
food policy research institute welcome
to dw um can we start with your reaction
to the news of this deal
so it's a good news because anything
that can help facilitate in trade in
particular in the black sea uh is nearly
trade your pressure on agricultural
markets so it's a good news for farmers
in ukraine and it's a good news for
consumers all around the world
trust has been a big issue of course in
during these months of negotiations what
do you think has made this agreement
possible now
i think there is a big question about
timing because on one hand it's very
important for ukraine to be able to
export
in the coming months with the new
harvest
coming
and they need basically to reopen their
markets and normally they export a lot
in the second half of the year also
turkey
is a big processor of both grains coming
from ukraine and russia and so in terms
of economic cost that's very painful for
the turkish economy to to maintain the
currency that you call and i would say
even russia that due to the disturbance
in the black sea is also paying a price
on its own export and its own access
in terms of maritime transportation for
their own goods
due to the level of uncertainty so
bringing back some normality in the
black sea
will provide benefit for the three
countries directly involved and last but
not least i mean potentially russia have
understood now that seizing odessa and
basically taking all the stuff of
ukraine is not a possible goal right now
and so they move to a new chapter right
and speaking of new chapters russia has
been accused of using food as a weapon
in its war with ukraine does this mean
that
this does this deal mean that that um
has stopped
so i will just be very confused about
the fact that russia has used
food and anger as a weapon i mean that
was a side effect
but clearly that was not their priority
so um maybe some
more cooperation among various countries
in the region yes but i will not say
it's a totally game changer about how
russia will behave on the ground uh and
they may still hurt
ukrainian agricultural infrastructure
for instance right now of course the
important thing is to get the grain onto
world markets and into shops
we don't know i suppose how long it's
going to take to to actually set this
deal up and actually get get working
before the grain can actually reach
people who need it
yes exactly i think the implementation
is going to be crucial
because what we really also need is an
agreement at scale if um let's say in
one month we just managed to get one or
two ships out of ukraine
um that's more or less i would say
nothing you know what we need is uh to
be able to have 20 30
ships a day that can go in and out of
ukraine if really we want to get
something that will be
close to normal
good talking to you thank you for
joining us david labord from the
international food policy research
institute
thank you
you